hello everyone
and welcome to today's session practical
mass
cytometry i am susie of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that
today's event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask
question box and click send we will
answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of each
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the ask a
question box located on the far
left of your screen today's session
includes speakers
dr tim bushnell dr garrett haga
bringland
and greg hopkins each presentation
and q a time will excuse me each
presentation will have a q a time
following their individual presentation
and now i present today's first speaker
dr
tim bushnell associate professor
department of pediatrics
and director of shared resource
laboratories at the university of
rochester
presenting on measuring photons and ions
impact on panel design signal detection
and data quality for a complete
biography on dr
bushnell please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
dr bushnell you may now begin your
presentation
hello my name is tim bushnell i'm the
director of the shared resource
laboratories at the university of
rochester
and i'm pleased today to be here to
present this talk on
measuring photons and ions and
especially on the impact
these have on panel design signal
detection and data quality
just for those who might worry i have no
conflicts to disclose
realistically speaking the goals of
today's talk are
by the end of this talk i hope you'll
have an understanding about the
difference between measuring photons and
ions
further the differences between
traditional fluorescent flow cytometry
and i'll be using this abbreviation ffc
and mass cytometry or mc in relation to
the design of high dimensional panels
and we'll highlight kind of some of the
similarities and differences
and last but not least i want to take a
brief moment to talk about the impact on
the resulting data from both flow
fluorescent flow and mass cytometry
there'll be several presentations on
more
detailed data analysis i just want to
highlight a couple of points for for
people to think about
so to start with i want to just go
through a review of how a flow cytometer
works
and so this is a slide from thermo
fisher's
school of fluorescence and as you all
know
cells are hydrodynamically focused they
pass by
a laser intercept where they
are the fluorochromes are excited where
the cells block light
and we measure that with detectors like
photodiodes and photomultiplier tubes
the signal is converted from a photon to
an electron and that's what we measure
here
that goes into our digital processing
and eventually
out as our data if we look at a mass
cytometer like the scitoff
it has a very similar pathway we have to
label cells but in
this case they go into a nebulizer and
they are sprayed out into the plasma
where the cells are vaporized and the
molecules are charged
the ions are charged and we have these
clouds here now we have this set of
quadrupoles
and the goal of these is to filter out
the really small
ions that we don't want to measure
things like carbon and nitrogen
etc from there they go into this
time-of-flight mode and we'll look at
that in a little more detail
where they're pushed to speed they go
through
and make it turn and come back down the
lighter the
ion the faster it reaches the detector
and
then it becomes a signal and like any
other signal like flow we can have
traditional flow cytometry data
fcs file there is some processing that
has to go
on but we get those files and we can
look at the data
and here's some resulting data comparing
the same panel the same staining using
traditional fluorescence
and mass cytometry as you know in
flow cytometry we use forward scatter
and we'll talk about that
later in mass otometry we use event
length
you can see we see similar profiles here
we can see our t
regs again we can see say the same
things and we're able to measure
what we can measure with traditional
flow in mass cytometry
now the biggest difference between these
two is obviously the reporter element be
it a fluorescence
or an ion tag and i just wanted to
highlight the two processes
particularly fluorescence and the issues
with fluorescence
as well as the advantages so here we
have a spectral view
of several different molecules this one
here is alexa 488
this one here is a pe tandem die
and as you can see from these we have
excitation and emission
profiles those are dashed lines and each
molecule has a different excitation
profile
and depending on how we where we excite
that molecule is going to dictate the
output energy
because as you know in fluorescence a
fluorescent molecule captures a photon
of light
after the molecules of that are the
fluorochrome are excited
if and then fall back down to ground
state it emits a photon of a higher
wavelength the higher the energy of
excitation the higher the energy of the
emission
and so that means we want to be high on
these excitation profiles for example
here with a 48 nanometer laser you can
see we're
pretty close to the maximal excitation
of this alexa floor dye
pe on the other hand as you can see has
several different excitation points from
488
532 to 561 the higher we get up here the
better
the energy output now the other thing
about fluorescence is it's not
a nice discrete single process so these
profiles here
are probability curves of the photon
that will be emitted most probable
photons will be emitted here about 519
nanometers
as you can see this can emit way out
into the 600 nanometer range
so when we detect fluorescence we're
using photomultiplier tubes or avalanche
photodiodes and we have to put filters
in front of these
to attenuate the signal that goes to the
pmt or the apd
because pmts and apds are going to do
what they do as
if any photon hits them they can't
discriminate so that's
these colored boxes represent different
filters
that would be potentially on this
instrument and as you can see
we're going to have some overlap this is
all very standard
flow cytometry and if we think about
this fluorescence detection
as i said the input photons are
converted to electrons in a proportional
manner
we use these optical filters to control
the spec specific photons that reach the
filter
in flow cytometry it's very important to
characterize the detector because the
detector sensitivity
is going to impact the sensitivity of
your assay and the sensitivity of your
results
there's a couple ways to do that if you
have a pmt based system i use the mac or
trotter method um
if you have something like the cytoflex
apd method there's a paper that was
recently published it talks about how to
characterize that so if you don't have
your instruments characterized i
encourage you to do that
this is an important critical step and a
lot of core facilities do this but if
not you might want to do that yourself
and of course the other thing we want to
look at is this idea of the sensitivity
of our system where are the
detectors most sensitive where detectors
have the most
error contribution and this paper here
from mario's lab talks about this it
talks about a concept called spectral
spillover
the spectral spillover matrix and this
can be calculated in
automatically in the flow just software
package before flow joe did it we did it
manually
and this is the results of that so you
can see here if i look at a fluorochrome
like pe ci5
you can see that it contributes you know
6489
fluorescent units to the error of the
system so that means
so that is what's contributed to the
detector if we look at a detector like
this one here
which is receiving about 8 000
channel values of error that means
before we can even make a sensitive
measurement
we're almost at 10 to the fourth so
we've lost all that resolution
and this is one of the big concerns in
fluorescent flow cytometry is that loss
of resolution
and that will impact our panel design
now if we turn our attention to how do
we detect ions
if you haven't thought about it here we
go so in the mass cytometry we're
actually measuring
the charge to mass ratio of ions we're
going to take an uncharged
metal an uncharged particle we're going
to ionize it
give it a positive charge and then it's
going to
travel into this system and this is uh
the the scitov technology is based upon
this idea of the orthogonal acceleration
time of flight system
in time-of-flight mass spectrometry the
longer the distance you have
the greater the separation can be
achieved
so there are some machines that have
meter long
or more tubes to to achieve that
resolution
in that separation in the scitov using
this or you know in the orthogonal
acceleration
what happens is we have a reflector here
and as the ions come in
they're reflected and turned back guided
towards our detector
interestingly the detection side of the
cyto is similar to a pmt
that is the charged particle hits the
detector which ejects an electron the
signal is then amplified based upon the
principles of secondary emission
where one electron hitting the surface
induces the emission of more electrons
this current is captured by a time to
digital converter that has a
4.5 order of magnitude detection range
so i hope you're still with me so far
because now i want to talk about
briefly the limitations of fluorescence
detection and
i'm not here to beat up on fluorescent
flow cytometry i love flustered flow
but i just want to highlight some of the
differences in limitations of
fluorescent detection
as well as the some of the limitations
with ion detection which we'll talk
about in just a minute
so each fluorochrome has unique quantum
yield and this
translates into the brightness of that
molecule
and we can measure that brightness in a
wide variety of ways and we can rank our
florochromes based upon how bright they
are
but that brightness also impacts how
easy we can make a sensitive measurement
for it for that given molecule of course
emission as i mentioned is not discrete
and one of the reasons
this is a issue is because it leads to
this concept of compensation which is
where we're going to care
correct for that spectral spillover
between channels
and ensure that we can measure our
single molecule
single fluorochrome in the presence of
all these other fluorochromes that we
have there
additionally in in fluorescent flow we
have to worry about auto
cell autofluorescence as you know cells
based upon size or complexity
can have higher autofluorescence which
makes which again can limit
the sensitivity in some channels
it sounds like again we're we're bashing
it but again these are the fat you know
these are important concepts
as you think about panel design things
like
far red excitation 633 excitation and
far red emissions
are less energetic photons than
something coming off of a 488 or a 560
you know two laser what that translates
into is we need to collect more photons
to be able to get a good measurement
increasing the cv of the data the spread
of the data increases
uh apds are a little bit better uh in
this region than
pmts are but it's still
a concern of course we get back to the
whole loss of sensitivity when you have
18 or 19 or 20 or 40 colors fluorescent
tags in a one mile in one panel and last
but not least if you're doing
intracellular staining
fluorochrome size and fluorochrome
choice can impact intracellular staining
think of the difference between a small
molecule like alexa 488
and a fluorescent protein like
phycoerythrin
which is going to be easier to get in
and which can be easier to clean and
wash
and stain so those are considerations
you have to make
if we turn over to the mass cytometer
and talk about
issues with limitation limitations with
ion detection the first issue we have to
worry about is a purity of the metals
some metals are found in nature at 100
purity but not
all are and so 100 purity is not
practical for those we can
uh purify them to 97 98 99 percent
and so that's going to require us to
have make some correction factors
in our data this is probably the largest
contribution to background in our scitov
experiments
a second factor that happens is the
oxidation of the metals
now the oxidation of the metals is very
metal dependent
some metals oxidize more easily and what
will happen is you'll now see a
the the value the the metal then you'll
also see a plus 16 species
so because it's predictable we know
which metals are better
and worse at worrying about this which
will help us in when we design our
our panels sensitivity again another
problem is that
as the mass peaks the mass peaks can
broaden the cv gets wider
due to small differences based upon the
position and the velocity when they
enter the chamber
this is uh often termed the m plus one
last but not least in fluorescent flow
we're used to
measuring physical parameters forward
scatter and side scatter
when we ioni when we uh vaporize our
cells we
lose those parameters there's no force
getting those sides together
stern published a paper in 2017 where
they used
a couple of different methods osmium
tetroxide
and a wheat germ a gluten and staining
to to show that they could use that to
give you a rough
forward scatter profile this is a
limitation because we're used to it but
a lot of the way
gaity and i do and we'll see for example
the clinic they've gone away from using
ford scatter for
detection in my gating strategies i
don't use ford scatter size getter in a
way to identify molecules i only use it
to get rid of debris and things
so this is really a limitation but it is
something for people to consider
all that together how do we design a
panel a lot of the pat
things are going to be similar there's a
couple of differences that we're going
to have to worry about
so the first consideration when we
thought talking about panel design
is the antigen density one of the things
we like to talk about
is pairing low expressing antigens with
very bright or more sensitive markers
and very highly expressed antigens say
cd3
with a less bright marker a dim marker
now the question is always ask well what
is the antigen density of
of a molecule and two papers came out
quite recently that i think are great
useful tools this paper from
uh calena at all characterized
a hundred antigens using fluorescence to
characterize different
profile patterns in i want to say it's
30 plus different subsets you can
actually get this data
and look at this data yourself to
analyze it and then be able to
identify which which markers are
expressed or
highly expressed or less highly
expressed on your target cells
now amir and colleagues did the same
thing but they used siteoff data for
characterization and in fact
they did a really nice study where they
actually use automated analysis to to
generate that
so whatever you're doing i recommend you
get these papers to help you improve
your
experimental design so that you know
what you know relative ranking of
different fluorochromes or observe
different antigens
now the second thing we have to think
about as i've mentioned already
is the marker intensity now in
fluorescent flow cytometry the idea is
to pair brightly expressed antigens
with less bright fluorochromes and you
can get tables like this from bd
bioscience
bio legend has them and stuff and they
give you a ranking of very bright to the
dim
of different fluorochromes based upon
excitation profile
the caveat with all of these tables is
that they're laser-dependent
these are power dependent and
filter-dependent and if you don't have
the same laser power and filters you
need to
you this isn't going to give you a lot
of the best information
it's something that i encourage
facilities to make themselves
so that they can share those with with
the groups that they work with
it doesn't take that long to do one of
the other issues with these marker
staining indices is that every time a
new fluorochrome comes out you have to
redo this and add it to the list
in mass cytometry again we're going to
pair highly expressed antigens with
less sensitive metals and this is a
chart from
uh from florida and you can see here the
sensitivity this is a
0.8 and this is you know one so you've
got a range of very
very bright very uh sensitive metals and
you have a range of less sensitive
metals so
down here we're going to use for things
like you know again cd4 cd8 and here we
would be looking for emergent markers
um and emergent dyes uh mergent antigens
now just just to make
a brief statement we i keep talking
about this idea by brightness
and how we measure this and this this
article from uh
sean bendall and colleagues actually
looked at the
signal staining index
between scitoff and fluorescent flow
cytometry
with different fluorochromes and
different um
conjugates and you can see here pretty
much across the board
the scitov have a lower relative
staining index than the fluorescent
detection
one of the issues however is you have to
remember that
in fluorescent flow we have a lot of
background
and we need to have this brightness is
important so we have make sensitive
measurements
in the cytop we don't have
autofluorescence we don't have
uh an equivalent of that
and so we don't the less sensitivity may
is fine because we don't have the same
background
and in that case a zero on a scytof
experiment is a zero because there's no
metal there whereas a zero on a flow
cytometer could be due to
uh due to background due to
autofluorescence due to compensation
so that's not all you want to do when
you're trying to build a panel
is again we're always looking for this
try to make the most sensitive
measurement
and so just using the brightness of one
antibody or the other is
is is good but what we really want to
look at is that
uh spectral spillover matrix and here's
an exa that i showed before
this is a full matrix for an instrument
and you can see areas that are green
are interactions and relationships where
you might want to
use to make a very sensitive measurement
areas that are red are areas that you
want to avoid
this is all measuring that loss of
resolution i know you can't read the
numbers
because it's a pretty big table but
that's the whole idea behind this when
i'm sitting down to design a panel for
fluorescent flow i've got this chart up
on one window
i've got my uh panel design tool in
front of me and i've got my data as to
what type of
expression level and antigens i need now
there's nothing applicable to this
in mass cytometry that i have seen other
than the sensitivity measurement that uh
that we just showed so we don't have to
worry about this loss of resolution
in mass cytometry last but not least
something we have to consider for both
uh studies is the idea of the resolution
impact
and the idea is that what is the
resolution loss
due to a coexpressed markers and this is
just showing you an idea when you're
designing a panel
if you draw out kind of what part
molecules you're looking for
you can start to see for example here
these cd3 cd4 and cd25 are all
co-expressed on regulatory t cells
now in fluorescent cytometry this can
cause a problem and this has been
measured by something called the
resolution impact
and this is uh no there's no equivalent
for mass cytometry
but again this shows you what pairs of
fluorochromes you need to put together
handle design both of them
look for the antigen density both of
them pair
highly expressed antigens with less
sensitive
reporters and poorly expressed antigens
with more sensitive brighter
reporters in cytometry then you have to
make sure you go through these other
steps
which are not required for mass
cytometry so there's a certain level of
ease of making a panel in mass cytometry
that is not available in
traditional flesh and flow
and so like i said who wins well you
know
mass cytometry is easier than
fluorescent flow
because one thing is you avoid
autofluorescence and spectral spillover
so you
improve the sensitivity a second thing
is that
it's much more predictable metal
purities
oxidases etc are very well characterized
and very well known and so it's very
easy to generate a correction matrix
based upon the knowledge that we have as
opposed to having to generate a
compensation matrix all the time
in flow cytometry one thing you do have
to worry about is
you know don't be a get you know get
used to looking
at the data in both cases
controls remain critical you can't
interpret the data without the proper
controls
things like fluorescent minus one
controls and and
or metal minus one controls depending on
the
your needs so you can really identify
the positives and the true
positives from the negatives costs are
comparable and i believe matt cochran
will talk about this at a round table
later on
so i won't go into detail but long story
short
you can it's about the same cost to run
the same a fluorescent flow panel as it
is a
mass a massotometry panel now one ding
on mass cytometry has been that is much
slower than fluorescent flow cytometry
in mass cytometry we're kind of limited
to you know physically limited to
probably no more than a thousand
cells per second whereas people will
tell you in mass psychology i can run
tens of thousands of cells a second
yes i can but running cells
fast in fluorescent flow increases the
spread of the data
so here we have a graph where we've gone
from low to medium to high
and these red lines represent the spread
of the data when we run it high and
these black lines represent the spread
of the data when we run it low
now you can see that there's a major
increase in the spread of the data by
running faster
so yes i can get a lot more events
through
but i'm going to have a bigger cv what
happens what does that mean that means
i'm going to
lose sensitivity so ergo
faster isn't always better and in fact
in higher dimensional panels it's
probably
it is better to run slower so that you
avoid this kind of
issue here
when we talk about data analysis now
that we've done all this is we can think
about three steps and both of these
apply
whether you're doing fluorescent flow or
mass cytometry and this is adopted from
vinco at the university of zurich and
the base idea is we want to visualize
our data first
and so we can do bivariate plotting
if you want to get into algorithms you
can do things like dimensionality
reduction so you can do something like a
disney plot
to to reduce the complexity of the data
to make it easier to
visualize on a two-dimensional plot
in manual gating or in manual analysis
we do gating we draw
regions around and we use these regions
to
do a data reduction to only identify the
target cells we want
whereas if we're going back to
algorithms we're going to use things
like clustering analysis
to be able to uh identify
the populations based upon how close and
how similar they are to each other and
again if you're looking at 30 dimensions
you can't this is valuable but at the
same time there's nothing stopping you
from doing
manual gating especially if you have
specific questions you're asking then of
course
you get into how do you compare the data
using various spreadsheets for your
statistical package versus software's
like you know citrix and others
and as i've said several times now um
there's no equivalent
to autofluorescence and mass cytometry
there are some caveats though
there are some environmental metals that
have been known to
contaminate um and these can come from
cleaning agents and things so
you may see those issues um cisplatin
and imaging contrast agents can
cause issues in your patient in in a
sample so
if somebody's undergone an imaging study
in the in
in a recent period of time it may be
good not to get
sampled that day there are been some
issues with argon purity we've seen this
in a couple of cases that
you know our argon isn't guaranteed to
be free of of contaminants and so we've
had some issues
that affect the sensitivity of our our
system
this is something we don't necessarily
have to worry about with traditional
flow because we can filter our
our fluids as i said there's no minimal
correction required in mass cytometry
because there's less spreading of the
data
and ultimately the zero is really a zero
so if we go back to looking at some data
here we have a
data from a flow run and from a cytoplan
the same sample stained with the same
antigens
uh either fluorescently labeled or
labeled with
ions you can are metals you can see
again we're going from a scale
here about 4.3 decades
here we only have four decades about 10
24 resolution
it's a little lower but you'll notice
right here
you'll see right at the zero we don't
really have anything
the events lining up at the zero and the
negative those are negative they're
truly negative there's no spread in the
same way we have
and we just have to accept that one of
the limitations of some of the ways we
display our data is that we don't
resolve the slow demand the slow region
here the first day
first decade as easily as we would like
as especially as easy if we were out
here
so people get a little bit uh frantic
about
seeing everything piled up in that one
little axis as opposed to fluorescent
flow where we have these big populations
spreading out
across you know into the negative region
but then you can see we get the same
populations
and we get the same percentages this is
just basic analysis but the important
thing
is that in ion detection we
we have advantages over fluorescent
flows like i said the limitations of the
spreading and things
um and that makes it easier for
us to build and design panels and
if we look at a you know if as i come to
the end of my talk and we talk about
kind of the advantages of
this like i said the losses lack of
autofluorescence and the loss of
sensitivity due to the spectral
spillover
means we can get better measurements we
can get tighter measurements more
sensitive measurements
again mass cytometry we have the the
fact that
it's uh the predictive there's
predictability in the correction factors
there's another nice feature in mass
cytometry is the ease of normalization
in fluorescent flow there's a lot of
discussion of how do i normalize my data
and there's a lot of
ways that people try to go around this
and and get to this point
but in mass cytometry it's been very
well established that the
by running a certain set of standards
we're able to normalize our data so that
the comparisons between
runs on day one and runs on day 50
can be made at the same way so we don't
we're not
fighting a large sensitivity issue
another nice thing about mass cytometry
is that stained cells can be frozen
and kept for a month
or so they're very they're very robust
we've had
samples sent to us at our facility uh
one in one case they sat on the the
tarmac
at a fedex location over the weekend and
when we put those cells on the system on
when we got them they looked they looked
fine and comparable to previous
samples so there's a lot of stability in
using these metals as opposed to using
fluorochromes especially if you start to
think about all the
you know either tandem dyes or protein
based
fluorochromes which can break down more
easily
panel principles again are essentially
the same in in the panel design
focus on the antigen density and the
reporter brightness
again in flow cytometry we have to worry
about the other issues about what
detectors give what sensitivity we have
to worry about laser power
we can change sensitivity to changing
those filters in front of our detectors
um and again we have to worry about this
co-expression on a given cell something
that
we see in fluorescent flow but is again
not so critical
in mass cytometry and last but not least
and there'll be a lot of talks about
data analysis uh elsewhere
and now gotta remember in mass cytometry
is zero is a zero
and while there's a a trend that people
say anything under 10
is is uh considered
negative what you really want to do is
use the appropriate controls to define
your positivity and your negativity
and don't just arbitrarily set a cutoff
because that's what you know that's what
the trends are that's what people are
saying it's the controls in your
experiment that are going to
guide you to gaining the data
so with that i'd like to thank you for
listening to me and i look forward to
answering any questions you might have
thank you dr bushnell for your
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have any questions you'd uh like
to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
let's get started uh hello pam
hello susie hi there
our first question is um you mentioned
that speed can be a factor
in choosing between fluorescent flow
cytometry and mass cytometry
can you further elaborate on the issues
with uh
speed of acquisition yes thanks cc
that's a great question
um when we're looking at data analysis
one thing i'm always looking at is what
the cv the spread of the data and in
fluorescent flow cytometry
as we increase the flow rate what
happens is the the core stream gets
wider
so the cv the data gets wider we get a
larger spread
that impacts our ability to make a
sensitive measurement and so when you
start to go to
20 25 30 parameters as you
lose resolution by because the cds
increase that's going to impact the
whole panel so it's better
in fluorescent flow to run at a slower
speed um
comparable to the speeds that we run
this at with the saito
which again i have some physical
limitations as to how fast we can run
so slower is better
thank you thank you um and it looks we
have looks like we have a question from
our audience here um
how is it that we see on scitop data
negative values
below zero that's a good question
and i don't have a good answer for you
because
in general we have not i've not seen
that in the data that i've i've analyzed
uh so i would have to look at your data
and do some comparisons so i can't
answer that hopefully in the data
analysis section they might be able to
talk about
why you might see that my guess is is a
processing issue
from the correction but i don't quote me
on that
um and we have another question from the
audience
what kind of standard can help to
compare the data
from the experiment run on different
days
so we have a collection of uh five or
six metals and i forget the exact number
that have been provided by
fluidim that we know the what the
intensity should be we know where they
should fall so we can standardize our
instrument
based upon that um those standards so
that we can make sure we have the same
sensitivity each time
it's similar to using a peak six speed
in in flow cytometry
when you're adjusting your pmt's but
it's a little bit more
robust than traditional in in flow
cytometry and so you can get that
normalization factor that makes things
very easy to analyze
okay great thank you um let's ask this
um in your opinion what kind of
tools would be needed to quantify
antigen
density by saitosh again
that's a great question i mentioned two
papers in the the talk
one by ella david amir uh that was
published in frontiers in immunology and
the other by thomas canela
also published in frontiers and
immunology uh last year
both of them set up us
a background or a backbone panel
and left channels open to analyze
different different uh antigens
and that data is readily available um if
you
download the papers for the
the fluorescent data from thomas uh you
know canalio's
group if you go to hcdm.org you can
actually get a link to their data set
and they have a very good display of the
different expression patterns of these
different images on different cell types
which is really
really valuable um and again with amir's
the data from amir's
you have the same thing and you can go
get their data they share all that as
well
great awesome well thank you so so much
for that awesome q a portion and um your
very informative presentation
uh we have a lot of questions coming in
but um
just as a reminder to our audience if we
didn't answer them verbally
there is record and um we can follow up
with speaker afterwards so
we're going to continue on with our next
presentations here
i now present to you our next speaker
actually we have
dr garrett hagar brinklin a
neurology resident at the hockland
university hospital
presenting presenting on monitoring
immunotherapy
with a mass cytometry receptor occupancy
assay
for a complete biography on dr bringland
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr bringlin you may now begin your
presentation
hi everyone and welcome to my lecture
i'm jared bringilan
i'm a neurologist stationed in bergen
norway
and i will talk about how we monitor
immunotherapy
with the mass cytometry receptor
occupancy essay
so first i will just introduce the
immunotherapy that i want to talk about
which is nataliethemap in multiple
sclerosis
and then i will present a mass cytometry
receptor occupancy essay and show
how we used nataliesima
receptor covalency to study therapeutic
efficacy
so first of all for those of you are not
familiar with the disease we're going to
talk about
multiple sclerosis or ms is a
neurological disease
where inflammatory lesions like the one
we see on these mri
scans of the same patient occur and
disappear
and cause neurological symptoms that can
be permanent
so this is actually one of the leading
causes of
neurological disability in young adults
globally
to prevent disease activity and
accumulating
disability we use immunotherapy
and one of the drugs we use is
natalizumab which this lecture will be
about so natalie's amount blocks
leukocytes from entering the central
nervous system the cns
and thereby prevents disease activity
so normally leukocytes can adhere to the
blood-brain barrier
using alpha-4 integrins which are
receptors on the surface
cross the blood-brain barrier and cause
inflammation in the cns
so nataliesimov is a monocle antibody
that blocks these alpha-4 integrins and
thereby
blocks inflammation in the central
nervous system
this drug is given intravenously by
infusions every four weeks
and every patient gets the same standard
dose
we still see some varying therapeutic
efficacy
so for most patients this drug is so
effective that they can actually extend
the dose intervals
for from four to six to eight weeks
without getting a reduced effect
so this this works for many patients
but the problem is we don't always know
which patients
can extend the doses on the other hand
about 50 percent of patients report
what we call wearing up at the end of
those intervals
so wearing off is a feeling of the
effect
wearing off the last week maybe before
infusion and this feeling goes away
after infusion
this is a phenomenon that we will talk
about later in the lecture
so because the therapeutic efficiency is
varying
between patients personalized dosing and
same
instead of giving the same standard dose
for everybody
has been proposed for over a decade
but this should be by guided by a
biomarker for a therapeutic 50
so you can patient tailor the dose for
each patient
one of these biomarkers that's been
discussed is receptor cuppancy which we
will talk about today
so receptor cuppancy is the proportion
of receptors bound by a drug on each
single cell so the ratio between number
of drug molecules bound
and the number of the target receptors
that the drug is supposed to bind
it's referred to as a percentage so in
our case the drug
is natalisma and the receptor is this
integrin
we know from other studies that receptor
capacity in natalysma
varies between patients and that it's
associated with
therapeutic efficacy so therefore it
could be a biomarker to
patient tailor or personalize dosing of
methodism
so we wondered if we could measure
receptor cuppancy with
mass cytometry this is
usually done by flow cytometry but the
advantage of mass cytometry is that this
would allow
measurement of receptor capacity
together with more parameters than
possible by flow cytometry currently
a problem is that the mass saturates
sensitivity
varies across the detection range of the
massachusetts this is expressed in this
figure where we see same amount of
metal ions sent through all the mass
channels but the sensitivity differs a
lot so
some areas of the detection range are
more sensitive
than other areas
so in our case we wanted to measure
integrin
relative to non-laser map so we would
use different antibodies for detection
of those two
and because they're different metal type
their attacks on these
antibodies the detection sensitivity
would differ
so the problem is that receptor
occupancy is a ratio
so if the detection sensitivity for drug
and receptor is different
different this would affect the ratio so
you would get the wrong results
so we wondered if receptor coppency can
be measured
accurately with mass cytometry
and the essay that we developed together
with the
people in berlin is
well described in this paper that we
published last year so you can get all
the details if you want there
i will just walk you through the
principles
so in flow cytometry antibody binding
beads are used
to address a similar problem we use
antibodies
tagged with them different brightness
you can use antibody binding beads with
no numbers of these antibodies bound to
their surface
to standardize between those antibodies
if you want to compare them
these beads are a cell sized
microscope or microfares and they're
made of out of polystyrene so
they do not contain any metal in the
detection range of the mass cytometer
themselves so they the beads themselves
are invisible to the mass cytometer
they are then saturated with antibodies
and we can see here in this figure
this is from mass cytometry the beads
with high antibody binding capacity
which are
on there right here they can be readily
identified because they are
bound and they have a lot of antibodies
down to their surface and a lot of metal
content
but the lower beads have so few
antibodies down that they
fall below the detection threshold so
this makes it impossible to use these
beads
on my citrometry as they are
so to solve this we use
osmium tetroxide osmium tertoxide
binds to the polysiren inside the beads
and makes the beads detectable in the
osmo channels of the mass cytometer
so then the beads can be identified here
and also in the channel of the antibody
that is
this is also described in the paper from
a paper from
the berlin group where they use it for a
different purpose than ours
so then we can adapt these beads for use
in mass cytometry
when we can use these beads we can then
use
known numbers of antibodies bound to the
beads
to create standard curves so we have
these two antibodies that we want to
compare
we saturate beads with increasing
numbers of amp
antibodies bound to the surface and we
create standard curves
so these are standard curves between the
signal intensity of
each of the beads for each of the
antibodies
and the known numbers of antibodies that
these beads have bound to their surface
then we can take our samples with
unknown numbers of antibodies
so we want to compare these two
antibodies
we can then plot them into the standard
curves and read out the number of
antibodies or what we call standardized
numbers
before we compare them in the receptor
cuppancy
ratio
so the effect of this can be seen from
our results
these are cells that have been in vitro
saturated with drugs so we know that
they have a receptor occupancy of 100
percent
so hundred percent this is the other
line and we see to the left here
that that beats with um that the samples
are the receptor occupancy of the
samples it's overestimated
about by 125 percent
this is because in our case the drug was
detected more sensitively than the
receptor so that's why
the receptor coupling is overestimated
when we use the beat standardization of
drug and receptor before we calculate
the receptor occupancy we see that we
get a
result that is almost exactly what we
expect so a median of 100 percent
so we conclude that the antibody binding
beads
that are used in flow normally can be
adapted to mass cytometry to allow
accurate receptor coupling measurement
we used it for natalie sima but the
method can be adapted to any other
therapeutic antibody that binds to a
receptor where you want to
calculate a ratio so this goes for a lot
of different antibody therapies
also used in all other immunotherapies
and
cancer therapy where these two
antibodies
that are supposed to be compared are
detected to some degree
by different sensitivity
so back to our clinical question
uh in nonlistener therapy as i mentioned
around half of patients report wearing
off symptoms at the end of dosing
intervals
these are often subjective things
symptoms like fatigue
and the cause of the phenomenon is not
known
and it's been assumed to be purely
psychological
this is often a shortcut that the
clinicians take when they don't know
if there's something has an explanation
it's often
claimed to be psychological
so we wanted to see if receptor capacity
was associated with
wearing off symptoms we know that the
receptor occupancy is highest
right after reinfusion and then slowly
decreases towards
the time for refill which is normally
four weeks
so we started this in a paper that was
published earlier this year where you
can read
all the details and i will walk you
through just the
main steps of the study so this was a
cross-sectional study of
40 patients with ms who received
naturalism up
in our department we collected blood
before and after
infusion with natalisma
we isolated peripheral blood leukocytes
pbl
and we stained with an antibiotic
cocktail containing a lot of different
antibodies and antibodies
for detection of integrin and natalie
small
parallelly we stained antibody binding
beads with
osmium tetroxide to adapt them to mass
cytometry
and then we saturated their surface with
the same two antibodies for detection of
integrin and
metallism we ran the beats
and the samples on mass cytometry and
did reception occupancy analysis
we did two analysis pipelines both
manually and more automated i will
just walk you through the results here
so we find that patients with wearing
off symptoms regularly
meaning at the end of every single
dosing interval
have lower receptor occupancy and
several pbl subtypes
than patients who had such symptoms
never or only sometimes
at the end of dosing intervals this is
the blood sample taken before
infusion we see 11 cell subtypes and
this is a spider plot showing receptor
occupancy from 0
to 100 in each cell type
so the blue line here is patients with
symptoms regularly at the end of every
dosing interval
and the median receptor cuppancy is
lower in all the cell types as we see
here
it's only statistically significant
though in the cell
types that are marked by a red star
and the blood samples collected after
infusion we see the same pattern where
the blue line is
uh at the inner of the other line is
except in one cell type so the median is
lower and almost all subtypes also only
significant in their
cell types marked by a red star
this was the first indication that this
phenomenon wearing off
may have a biological cost so this was
very exciting
we controlled our results with their
other analysis pipelines where we use
more automatic
analysis with citrus
so here's the same cell types as we
looked at
in the manual analysis overlyid and a
disney map
and these are the citrus results
overlaid on the same business map
so we asked the algorithm to see if
there was difference in receptor
covalency between
the patients groups with wearing off
symptoms
and sometimes regularly or never
and so the orange dots here are cells
where
the receptor compensate differs between
the groups
and when we look at the results we see
that the patients with wearing up
symptoms regularly have
lower receptor occupancy than the two
other groups
this was also seen in the blood sample
taken
after infusion
when we looked at the bmi of the
different patient groups we saw that
patients were wearing up
symptoms regularly had higher median bmi
we compared bmi and receptor cochlearcy
we saw that patients with higher bmi
had lower receptor cuppancy
so these are the different uh cell types
and the
the full drawn lines are the
statistically significant
cell types
we did not find an association between
wearing
off and what we define as therapeutic
failure with natalie's
but we found that patients were wearing
off had more
sick leave and they had poorer fatigue
and cognitive scores when we followed
them up for one year
so how do we interpret these findings
we hypothesize that higher bmi
is associated with lower receptor
cuppancy
which is often seen in different drugs
that
people with high body weight need need
more drug
to get to the right place in the body
the target receptors
so patients with high bmi get lower
receptor coupling
and we think that this may lead to a
sub-optimal efficacy of the drug
especially towards the end of the dosing
interval
when every patient has lower receptor
cuppancy
than at the beginning of the dosing
interval
and we believe this is the cause of the
wearing off effect
this could also be the cause of these
patients having more fatigue cognitive
impairment and sick leave
so this phenomenon which is mostly
what we call subjective signs or not
very hardcore signs of
disease activity fatigue cognitive
impairment sick leave and subjective
feelings of the
effect wearing off may be explained by
this biological parameter and not by
only
psychological factors
wearing off was not associated with what
we call therapeutic failure
but ms-related fatigue and cognitive
impairment are
poorly captured by these conventional
definitions of trophy failure
although it's very debilitating for the
patient
it's typically overlooked by the
neurologist because we focus more on
mri signs or
policies or these things that we can
measure with our tools
also in the context of individualized
dosing
wearing off because it's associated with
lower receptor capacity
may increase the risk of therapeutic
failure in extended interval dosing
so i mentioned that many patients
can extend the doses from the dosing
intervals from four to six to eight
weeks
without getting therapeutic failure but
the wearing off
group may be more vulnerable to
therapeutic failure
if the dosing intervals are extended
so these were the results of our
project but why would we measure
receptor occupancy with mass cytometry
so as i said mass statometry allows
measurement of receptor compensate
together with more parameters
so that means we can measure it in more
cell types and also together with
more other possible biomarkers than
current before
possible by close atometry
so our results in this studies could
have been overlooked if we had analyzed
less cell types so we see here only a
few cell types
are statistically significant maybe
because we had a few patients in our
study
and and if we had only looked at a few
uh cell types that were not
statistically significant
and we could have overlooked this these
results
this was actually done by a group that
did a similar
study with flow cytometry that was
published a few months before
ours and they found trends
in the same direction in a direction as
our results but they were not
statistically significant
they only looked at two cell types so if
they would have done a
broader study of different cell types
they may have concluded in another
direction
so we used antibody binding beads for
receptor coppency analysis
but in flow cytometry these beads are
also used to standardize between
different cytometers and over time
so if this could have been adapted to
mass cytometry
we may be able to standardize mass like
temperature data in multicenter and
longitudinal studies which is a need
that has been expressed by many people
and is not met by the current
standardization
protocols for mass cytometry
and we had to stain the beads with
osmotic oxide first which is a
very toxic compound and needs a lot of
washing steps of the beads before we can
start the antibody staining of the beads
so antibody binding beads containing
metal in the detection range of the
mass cytometer and would simplify the
protocol a lot if the beads already
contained
metal so these were some future
wishes for using beads in mass cytometry
and with that i want to say thank you
for listening and watching
and acknowledge my supervisors my
study center and of course the flow
cytometry facility in bergen where
all the analysis were performed thank
you very much
thank you dr ringling for this
informative presentation
uh we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on the
ask a question box located at the left
of your screen let's get started our
first question for you
is um is there a rationale for measuring
ro in many different cell subtypes
instead of
for example measuring mean ri or excuse
me r
o in all leukocytes yeah can you hear me
yes we can yeah so
uh for natalie zuma we don't know which
cell types are more or less important so
some have hypothesized that that some
cell types are more important for the
effect
and so are more important for side
effects of
treatment so as we don't know which
cell types are important and
how the different receptor occupancy can
kind of affect the
balance between effect and side effects
it's
important to not leave any cell types
out so mass cytometry is a good tool
when we don't know which cell types to
study
thank you um can there can the
different sensitivity between my metal
tags be predicted and corrected
for based on prior knowledge of the
sensitivity pattern
so we know kind of um roughly how the
sensitivity pattern varies across the
detection range
but this is an individual pattern
for different mass cytometers we also
see a
difference the site of one and two has a
bigger
sensitivity difference than the helios
machines
and and also the existing tools don't
allow you to actually
use the actual metal tagged antibody to
do this
you would use beads filled with metal or
a tuning solution or something like that
so this makes you actually able to
also correct for for example batch
effects and
metal content between antibodies
so the existing tools can't correct for
this
thank you um are there
examples of personalized medicine based
on
ro studies so for
for any drug i'm not sure i don't have
an overview of
all the drugs in the world but for
a natalie's mob a problem has been that
we don't know
the cutoff like what's the perfect
receptor cuppancy or what's
like the minimum receptor cuppancy so
this
uh there there's a lack of studies where
you look at what receptor capability
gives the a good clinical effect
so that's uh why we should um
also standardize the the receptor
compensate assay so we can actually
compare studies to find a cut off
clinically
that's irrelevant that makes sense thank
you
um and it looks like we might have uh
maybe question for one
time for one or more questions um now
forgive me as i mispronounce this
because i know i will uh we have a
question from our audience that
does nada liz zoo mob
yeah yeah um itself have any side
effects
side effects with increasing bmi
so um there's the main or
the side effects that worries us the
most is
pml which is like an infection in the
central nervous system
which is caused by the leukocytes
actually not accessing the central
nervous system to throw out
pathogens so this side effect does not
increase with bmi
actually it's been indicated from
previous studies that
increasing bmi partly protects from this
side effect
which kind of indicates what we show
that
probably a high bmi leads to lowers
after occupancy and lower effect of the
drug and the
lower dose dependent side effects so
there's not a the uh it's it's
um in that way you can kind of say that
the the lower the effect of the drug the
lower the risk of side effects from the
drug
great thank you so much for your time
today and all your important research we
really appreciate your time with us
um we're gonna go ahead and continue on
to our next presentation here
i now present our last speaker greg
hopkins who is the
senior associate scientist at bluebird
bio presenting
process development and clinical
assessment of car t
cell products for a complete biography
please visit the biography tab at the
top of the screen
mr hopkins you may now begin your
presentation
hi everybody my name is greg hopkins i'm
from a company called bluebird bio thank
you for having me here today
um today i'm going to be talking to you
about
how we use mass cytometry to uncover a
specific
memory t cell like phenotype um in one
of our carte manufacturing processes
so how i'm going to organize this talk
today is in a few basic sections
first we'll talk about the introduction
to the company i work for
just in bluebird bio that'll include
some of our clinical programs that we
have
and how we manufacture our car t cells
next we'll go into how i use mass
cytometry and our
different car t studies that we have
we'll go a little bit into the results
and some of the correlations that we've
made from those results
then finally we'll conclude and offer
some next steps that
we could work on as we go forward
before we get started i just wanted to
make some disclosures
miami currently employed and i currently
hold stock within bluebird bio
so now to get into a little bit who
bluebird bio is
and what we do so firstly bluebird bio
is a biotechnology company we're based
in cambridge massachusetts
which is right next to boston and
we are focused mostly on gene therapies
for severe genetic diseases
such as sickle cell disease beta
thalassemia
but we also are very much in the sphere
of cellular immunotherapies for cancer
also known as immuno oncology
and a few of these therapies are shown
here on the left
we have two current car t therapies that
are
in phase two phase three and one of
those is
known as bb 2121 and it's an
anti-bcma-directed car t
therapy and i'll get more into in a
couple of slides what bcma
is the other therapy that we have is
21 21 7.
this is uh something that we'll be
focusing on in this presentation
both of these different programs are
aimed towards treating multiple myeloma
and similar to bb 2121 2121-7
is an anti-bcma car t therapy and it's
currently under clinical investigation
for the treatment
of relapsed or refractory multiple
myeloma
as is shown here it's currently in phase
two
we currently have many different
programs that are in various stages
but those are those are getting
earlier stage than the bb 2121
and 2121.7
i should iterate that all of these
products are investigational
so right now we're investigating the
safety and efficacy but it has not yet
been established
so none of these project products have
yet been approved for use by any health
authority
but our whole sincere hope is that they
are soon
so let's get into now how the car t
cells are manufactured
it all starts with a leukopheresis
the patient's blood is drawn and the
peripheral blood
um is then isolated uh
by a like a fico gradient separation
we isolate the pbmc using this method
and the pbmc are our starting material
that we would begin our cartoon
manufacturing process with
the cells are then transduced with the
lentiviral vector
and then the t cells are expanded with a
selective
expansion cocktail and then this is
grown in a bioreactor for about seven to
ten days
at this point the car t
drug product is now made so this is a
final product that's grown and these car
t drug products
are able to be infused into a patient
so it goes all the way from the patient
being drawn with their own cells
to the medicine that is uh then
formulated at the end of this process
so bp 21 21 and 21 21
7 as i had mentioned are directed
towards bcma
this is for the treatment of multiple
myeloma
for a little bit of background multiple
myeloma is a cancer
of plasma cells and it's often
characterized by
hyper proliferation of the malignant
plasma cells in the bone marrow
this can result in renal failure anemia
and a common symptom
that presents is often bone fractures
despite many recent advances in
treatment multiple myeloma is typically
characterized by
persistence of residual disease in
multiple periods of remission and
relapse
it's often regarded as a disease that's
treatable
but is not curable
and these are directed towards something
called bcma this is b
cell maturation antigen it's almost
exclusively found on the surface
of differentiated plasma b cells and
it's highly expressed most importantly
on the surface of malignant plasma b
cells that often characterize multiple
myeloma
so this seems to be a very sort of
specific therapy to these types of cells
and how this works really with a car t
cell is that we have
a viral vector so in this case it's a
lentiviral vector
that encodes a specific car t construct
into the t
cell that includes a signaling domain
and a tumor binding domain
it engages the tumor cell and this is
what initiates the killing
of multiple myeloma tumor cells that
express
bcma
what we're focusing in on today is this
bb-21217
bb-2121-7 uses a specific pi3-kinase
inhibitor which we call bb007
so in our typical carte manufacturing
process
we expand the t cells from the pvmc
using il2 in this process
with the pi3 kinase inhibitor
the car t's are expanded with il-2
plus our bb-007 compound
the reason we do this is to exploit the
this sort of t cell differentiation
model
what we're hoping for here is to
actually isolate these cells that are
more towards the memory lineages so your
t naive your t stem cell memory
and the central memory we hope to favor
these
with this particular process these cells
typically express markers like cd27
and cd62l these
are more likely to um to be long-lived
and potentially
more durable in a response
and we're using that in our running
hypothesis here that
car t cells that are enriched for this
more memory like t cell phenotype
may actually persist and function longer
than ones that aren't enriched for it
and they may function longer in models
of
of potential relapse or refractory
disease as
is often seen in multiple myeloma
and this persistence of the functional
car t cells after infusion
may be a determinant actually of the
duration of the response which is going
to really be key
as we evaluate this model
we had some early evidence that supports
that this particular compound
may could confer a more durable
anti-tumor response
so this was an in vivo study that was
done at bluebird
in-house with uh some of our our animal
studies that were done
so what this is a tumor model a
xenograft model
where a tumor was implanted into a mouse
a primary tumor
and then car ts were car t cells were
administered anti-vcma car t cells
what we can see here is that in this
primary challenge
both a standard car t cell and one that
is supplemented with this compound
controlled the tumor but then a
re-challenge of the tumor
was was then administered
and at this tumor re-challenge there was
no tumor growth in mice that were
treated with uh this particular
bb 21 21 7 process so with the pi3
kinase inhibitor
but the ones that did not have this pi3
kinase inhibitor
actually develop disease or outgrowth of
the tumor
after after it was administered so this
suggests
longer persistence of the anti-tumor
effect of the car t
due to the presence of this particular
compound
so now we're going to get into why uh
why are we using cyto for this project
and it really comes down to one major
question
we want to understand what
characteristics of the car t cells
within the drug
product so that final formulated
material that's being infused into the
patient
and how those correlate with patient
response
we're going about that using um
using a particular panel that we
developed in-house to sort of deepen our
understanding
of what this drug product is
to do this we used a 37 marker panel
that is split into some basic uh
t-cell sub-phenotypes that we hope to
deepen our
our understanding of the car t-cells
so some of the things that we were
looking for here were
obviously the the car itself so uh
actually being able to detect the car
but also we were looking at
um markers of lineage looking at the
memory potential of the t
cells their activation their exhaustion
their cytotoxic potential and using a
host of
intracellular and other nuclear factors
to kind of dive in
and get a little bit more granularity
into what may be going on inside of
these car t cells
we went about this by in a very broad
sense by
doing a t cell panel stain with this
panel
and we would do it on either pbmc or car
t
products that came from our crb 402
trial
which is the trial that uses this bb 21
21 7
product we acquired this on the helio
system
in many randomized batches and we did
analysis
both looking at single marker and
clustering
and we analyzed this data along with the
cl the known clinical outcomes that we
had
to determine possible correlative
biomarkers that we could use
to perhaps predict response in in future
studies
what we first noticed is that this pi3
kinase inhibitor does appear to enrich
for more memory like car t cells this
was seen broadly
in looking at just two markers here
so what we have are the pbm the level of
expression in pbmc
and also in our drug product which is
grown out from the pvmc
in in most of the donors we have uh
looked at
there is a clear enrichment for left one
left one is typically
expressed in a more early memory like
phenotype
cd57 conversely was a
marker that went down and cd57
is pointing more towards an effector
like or even
a marker of dysfunction of t cells
we then looked at a few other markers
in a more controlled study so
this controlled study had car t cells
that were expanded both using a standard
process so without this pi3 kinase
inhibitor
and then a process with the pi3 kinase
inhibitor
and we will looked at a whole host of
markers within this particular construct
and this was done across us several
different
um pmc lots that were then grown out to
car t
cells what we noticed was an enrichment
of memory markers
so here is shown a a visney map showing
the richmond of cd27
as a result of this pi3 kinase inhibitor
edition
we also looked at a bunch of other
markers though and
among all of the different cells that we
looked at we
noticed an enrichment of ccr7 and cd 27
most prominently
which is pointing towards a more naive
memory like phenotype
and then cd57 here was also
much down down regulated as
a result of this pi3 kinase inhibitor
so this is pointing towards it having a
less effector potentially
less dysfunction like phenotype
before we get into how particularly
these markers correlated with response
we have to really define
or set criteria for a response the
criteria here that we're using
is peak expansion of car t cells so
the expansion of the cartesian car t
cell's post infusion
but we're actually looking at this by
looking at the vector copy number
or as we're saying here c max misses
copies of the cart
carte construct within the cell how they
were detected
and high ac max is shown to be
highly correlated in the responders
and then in the non-responders have a
low c-max value
so when we speak about peak expansion
going forward
it's using this value of these the c max
so if we think about that transitively
and try to correlate
marker expression with the c-max and
and by extension their particular peak
expansion
we notice these same markers popping up
so both left one
and cd27 as we saw in in the previous
model that i showed
were positively correlated and then cd57
the marker that is more of a late
effector
perhaps a marker of dysfunction was
negatively correlated
so this is pointing to these markers
actually being associated
with peak expansion
we're now going to go a little a step
further and
look at the markers more as a whole in a
unsupervised analysis
so this is looking at all of the markers
that were in our particular panel that
we tried
and these markers essentially segregated
our
our pre patients into two main clusters
one where many of the patients had a
high c-max so six
out of seven which is shown here in the
red
the other cluster was patients that only
about half of them had a high c-max
so these this particular cluster didn't
have patients that
had perhaps higher peak expansion of
their car t
cells and what we noticed here
as we can see in this red rectangle
is that all of these are more effector
like markers
and in this particular cluster that had
um had a higher or
didn't have as many high peak expanders
we see an enrichment of more effector
like markers
and sort of less of these more memory
like
markers these memory-like markers are
shown
here in this particular rectangle
but what we are seeing is in this
cluster that did have more high peak
expanders
we see an enrichment of these more
memory-like markers
this is highlighted here cd57
is expressed to a high level in this
particular cluster
and then then in the cluster with the
high c-max there is a
clear enrichment clear high expression
of the more
memory-like markers so this is perhaps
pointing towards peak expansion being
associated with this more extended like
phenotype
so we've shown that this this phenotype
and peak expansion
can potentially be correlated but now
we're going to
look at this more for actual response
now this is looking at sustained
response
or uh which is defined as
a progression-free survival
in month six post infusion of the car t
cell
and we see a similar trend actually
popping up here
we do see a sustained two different
clusters popping out
so one with sustained responders which
is
many sustained responders which is shown
here in the red
and then one cluster here with less
sustained responders so again only about
half of them
that is shown here in this blue
within this cluster that had
high many high sustained responders
we again see a low effector-like
phenotype and then a more memory-like
phenotype
if we look in the second cluster with
less sustained responders
we see that same trend occurring with
cd57 as a marker that stand out
stands out but many of these markers are
higher the more effector like
perhaps more a heading towards terminal
differentiation and dysfunction
and then these markers that are more
associated with memory
are lower in this particular cluster
so now we've taken peak expansion and
shown correlation and
now we're starting to see that perhaps
response can be
associated with these same markers as
well which is really what we were trying
to predict by using saitaf
is can we correlate these markers with
response
so in summary we can show here that
bb007 or a pi3 kinase inhibitor that we
use in our manufacturing process
uh favors a more memory like and by
shown by some in vivo data
a long lasting t-cell phenotype
using the cyto-technology it was
identified
that drug products from this bb 21 21 7
process so the one that uses bb007
have t cells that express more memory
like and perhaps less
exhaustion like associated markers
drug products that have this memory like
phenotype
may be positively associated with high
peak expansion
and perhaps perhaps by by extension
response and even sustained response at
once six
in our crb 402 trial which tests this
particular product
is ongoing and our future cyto studies
are going to continue to use material
from this study
and aim to identify associated
signatures either to confirm what we've
already seen
or to perhaps uncover new signatures
so with that i'd like to conclude and
thank the following people
at bluebird bio there's a very extensive
drug product characterization team
that really helped move the study
forward and it wouldn't be possible
without them
we did get some help from the
dana-farber
saito uh in helping us get off the
ground and run some of our early samples
before we actually got our own
instrument
and then the following group of people
at fluidim who helped us design our
panel
uh and helped us work through some of
the early kinks that we had
and mostly uh most of all i'd like to
acknowledge the patients in this trial
who provided the material to
to help us study this this disease and
hopefully get to the bottom
of finding a cure for it someday
thank you
great thank you so much mr hopkins for
your informative presentation
uh that was very interesting uh we will
now start the q a portion
of the webinar uh if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now
just click the ask a question box
located at the far left of your screen
and uh so let's get started greg uh
first question i have for you
is the presentation mentions looking at
characteristics of drug products and how
those may positively
positively correlate with response
what about the pmpv
that those car t cells are manufactured
from
what characteristics might be correlated
with a better drug product
and by extension response
and it sounds like greg you might be on
mute if you want to just go ahead and
make sure
can hear me yes we hear you go ahead
again yep so that's a very good question
first i should say that the panel that
we use was very focused on t-cells
in that looking at the the pbmc
characteristics are obviously very
important
using the maxpar direct panel data from
that which is something that we use
will probably give us more insight on
those characteristics in the bbmc
but a few things that i can say about
that is
typically a more exhausted t cell within
like disease patient pbmc and
also the monocyte to or the the antigen
presenting cell
to t cell ratio those things may
influence
the ability to to actually have a
response later in your drug product
but none of that data is fully
conclusive
yeah great thank you thank you for that
um
another question i have for you is why
does the pi3k
inhibitor appear to enrich for a more
memory like car t cell population
so we're still investigating the the
mechanism of action
um on on that uh this pi3 kinase
inhibitor is actually
used currently is a treatment and
it does some things to sort of act on
the mtor pathway
um it's known to kind of arrest cells in
the like a g1 phase
and have some sort of anti-metastatic or
it
will act on things that are more
metastatic
uh characteristics in nature but that is
totally on
um in vivo these are ex-vivo samples so
the the mechanism of action may be
totally different it's still under
investigation
cool thank you thank you
another question uh was the phenotyping
shown
done on the product just prior to
administration or have you used
scitov to track the car t cells over
time
in the patients to see how their
function changes
so these were done i'd say just prior to
it there's like a formulated final
product and this is
samples are taken from it and it's
similar to the material that would go
into a patient
so yes it is is pre-infusion there is
some things that we have looked at
after infusion but it's been very short
term afterwards
and those results unfortunately at this
point i can't elaborate on that but
we have looked out to a short term
period afterwards
as far as some of the other studies that
you know i've looked at where they
looked years and years and years
in advance and saw persistence i think
that would be a very interesting
question
to approach someday
great and i think we have time for maybe
one more question
um for today uh where do the car t
cells go once in the body is there a way
to track them in different sites where
they're expected to attack the tumor
cells
extract from different sites um well
i would i would say that you know many
of these if it
is or they are lymphomas or they are
uh myelomas that um you know many you'd
go where
many of the interactions would take
place typically so those
areas of um gathering lymph cells
i'm not a clinician so i don't you know
i don't really know that elaborately
but i know like the many of these cells
these interactions may happen
in some of the lymph tissue lymph nodes
great awesome well thank you so much uh
for your time today and presenting your
studies with us
um before i uh before we go i'd like to
thank the audience for joining
us today and just remind you that any
questions submitted during this
on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via
contact information
that you provided at the beginning of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through september of 2021
and until next time i will say
thank you so much and make sure to check
out the booths in our virtual event
there's some really good information
over there and we'd love for you to
check out the booths
thank you so much and have a great rest
of your day